let me interrupt you to say we have the
man the myth the legend himself jonathan
tisdale
online jonathan
good to see you
yeah good to see you guys uh your
glasses look like they're a little
thicker since the last time we saw each
other
how are you doing
the true both the frames on the gl and
the glass yep nice
uh i'm fine i'm glad uh to finally get
through to you and just before the event
ends right
um
jonathan uh we got to ask you the
question directly because we've been
talking about it now normally speaking
the candidates it's a winner take all
tournament uh there's one challenger
that player goes on to play the world
champion isn't it wonderful isn't it
wonderful but we've been
making noises that
the titans guess there's no reach an
angle to this question is there yeah
well what's the current state of
magnus's uh
how how has magnus address the issue of
the world championship match
i don't think i know anything uh
that you don't already know um this
started i think more or less because i
i had an interview with with magnus just
before the his match in dubai with nepo
right and he dropped this really strong
hint that it was going to be his last
match and when i tried to press him on
it he said ask me after the uh
after the match i haven't had a chance
to ask him
but he has um
spoken to uh podcasts and
people in the
media here who he's very friendly with
you know his guys
um
his old friends and this sporting
podcast and stuff and his statements
have not been crystal clear yet but
they've become increasingly stronger
that
you have to take him seriously when he
says he is not uh
he's less to please less pleased than
ever
to to play a title match is how i'd say
it
wow and uh you
you've known magnus basically since he
was a little boy
and you take his
comments very seriously because he's not
the one to pull punches he tells you
exactly the way he feels
yeah exactly
magnus
yeah i mean it's quite the opposite in
fact you ask magnus a tricky question
and he will give you a horrifyingly
direct and
thorough summary of his opinion yeah i
mean he's he doesn't pull punches and he
he not only says what he means if he
says he's going to do something he
follows through
i that's why i you know i you have to
take it this seriously but the
biggest um positive so far is that he
hasn't said 100 he won't do it if he
says that i'd be astonished if he does
play but
he's kept this open and he's always
had this attitude
you know i mean it's easy to forget now
that
when he was um
you know the the heir apparent in the
you know the early 2010s if that's what
you call it that i mean he was so
against the
uh
the cycle the whole title cycle that he
dropped out of it right um
and he has you know said he doesn't like
the defending it and he doesn't like it
defining him i think that's maybe the
most
eloquent way he's put
his relationship with the title him what
do you think would be his ideal formats
just for everybody from the beginning
just
he does like the idea of no advantages
to the champion i mean he's not
trying
his his attitude towards the title isn't
protective at all yeah he has said many
times he'd like
some sort of completely open system i
suppose closer to this world cup kind of
thing than
what we have now but i mean he's also
been very clear and he's very fond
of
a rapid-based
event i think i think the current way
these uh his magnus tourists set up i
think
is a bit like his dream version of how
to run a
a
a championship event and i think he sort
of sees engines forcing people to play
so quickly that it's
at some point what we call classical
chess will be pretty fast nothing like
what uh yasser and i used to play
okay
right
but uh if for example these melt water
championship
events
where
they really are open and they're fast
paced
jonathan i got to tell you i mean the
well the norwegian television ratings
have been
spectacularly good that is
it it wouldn't be the worst thing that
ever happened to chess
no it reminds me a bit
of an interesting thing greg shahadi
said on twitter a couple of years ago
and it was one of these things where
when he said it it was clearly a
divisive thing to say and i agreed with
him 100 and disagreed with him 100 at
the same time so it was very memorable
but what he said was something about le
as to the effect that if
if we started running chess events now
no one would ever dream of
making them classical they'd all be
rapid right
and so that there's a sense that we're
carrying this you know historical burden
that games have to last
okay now they can only last all day
instead of several days like they didn't
when when we were young yes but um
basically
everything's going faster
and we see the necessity with the
engines to speed things up as well
and it's really hard for me to argue
against that that if we were starting
from scratch today we'd think oh yeah
you know it's a bit like the problem
qriket has
you can either play for five days or you
can
play rapid yeah so i think it's
it's very easy to understand how you can
see the game becoming
fast classical rapid
rapid rapid
rapid blitz uh you know and so on
alejandra jump in with a question for
our good friend uh jonathan tisdale if
you please well first of all great to
see you i was one of the few people that
was actually awake for breakfast in
dubai it's a very good breakfast company
was jonathan was regarding me with all
his stories guys i have to agree with
the conversation it's something that
i've been saying for years since i
started doing broadcast for the st louis
chess club i thought the game needs to
speed up we have candidates are going
they're regressing the world
championship to me this time control is
a regression it goes to our traditional
system to what we're used to but every
single new tournament
is going faster
yes
um
i'd say two things to that um
we
we still
supposedly see the need for a classical
title
um so presumably it's got to have older
well i want to say older slower
classical rules one thing that i do
think is really positive about
the last match through
and the candidates is that we brought
back good old-fashioned time control of
no increments before the game's actually
ending
which was the original idea
and it's not just because i like to see
people
in the same kind of time pressure that
was normal when yaz and i were kids you
know i mean real time pressure i mean
it adds
that element of
error creation and excitement that we've
been trying to achieve by just speeding
the game up
um
and you know
you get all of your time at the
beginning so you could actually have
more time for the game um
it's you know up to you to to invest it
properly
um so i think this is a really great way
of of sort of compromising while we're
working things out that people have real
time pressure
um
you have going to have a higher error
level which is what i suppose people
want yeah you want to increase the human
factor right and reduce the engine
factor
the problem for me with that is i can't
this i can't see it lasting as a
solution for very long because every
time you speed the game up your
classical lovers are going to go people
can't play really great games at this
speed right and then they do and you
speed it up and then they do so i assume
that they'll take a couple of months
before everybody knows how to invest
their time properly you won't get so
many time controls and we'll be in the
more less the same place
so
yeah
yeah i think you're gonna see it fast
and fast
i'm all for like having you know
revising the specific rules every like
seven to ten years just you know come
back to it make sure it's still relevant
to the player to the world champion to
well the game because i do feel like
after pandemic chess
has changed quite a lot
um yes but i do have another question
for you
i see that well as an author and as a
such a
amazing chess player and i also see your
beautiful bookshelves behind you so i
have to ask
um
what are your top three favorite chess
books that you must read anybody
everybody if you don't read it you got
to quit the games
oh that's really tricky because i i of
course i'll try and make give you a
weird answer um
well i gave you three i was gonna go for
a tough choice how many books how many
books did you write jonathan
well one of it has to be right right
i don't read i can't really answer i can
tell you one of the books i've always
recommended i don't think anybody's read
that's fair and that's and i won't even
be able to remember the name now
but it mihi's shuba's book on dynamic
chess something thinking
dynamic
that i've found incredibly inspiring and
um
showing me chess from a different angle
and also
literally laughing out loud constantly
throughout it it's full of fantastic
stories
personally i wish i'd read jonathan
rousen
when i was young but unfortunately
jonathan ross
zebras is my favorite i think because it
goes most deeply into
very normal problems with chest
psychology
and mental attitudes
and ways you can
um
mislead yourself and all sorts of really
deep topics that nobody tends to teach
you or you tend to think of yourself i
mean to me it was
personally i think i found it one of the
most instructive things i've ever read
and i immediately thought jesus if i
could have if he'd only been born before
me things might have been different
but dude i i want to slap you how come
you didn't immediately i mean
immediately say michael tall's
uh 1960 world championship match book
that's that's just like holy smokes
that's just unbelievable if i can find
out my bookshelf it's falling apart
it's a fantastic there are so many there
are so many
yeah so and then of course there's the
one we did together yeah yeah well thank
you i wanted it i was i i was leading
you to the water there you're drinking
um
to find on ebay or whatever it is to re
repeat back to you you're recommending
shuba's dynamic chests
any kind of stuff by jonathan rousen uh
really you like a a great deal okay
those are i mean i think those are very
very good choices by the way you wrote
also i think
what is play better chess now which
which improve your chest now very catchy
title misleading title i thought it was
a great book i mean did you get any
royalties
it's still it's still ticking in
actually um
yeah it's
no i mean people tell me it's some kind
of a classic i mean i loved it i thought
it was a great book i like jeremy
sillman too by the way i like authors i
i like branch dean i like john nunn i
think they're brilliant authors i like
larry christensen our old colleague i
mean we have to mention him i like john
watson and john i think he did a great
job with uh this chess strategy book
that he has i'm trying to remember the
name of it yeah but it was pretty modern
chess strategies maybe modern modern i
think it's modern chess strategy yeah
and uh devratsky anyone yeah yeah yeah
i was gonna say but that's a little too
obvious the other thing is right now i'm
really fascinated with what matthew
sadler's doing okay really fascinated by
you know being our uh translator and
guide to the uh the overlord world
i think his books are really fascinating
right um and there's a guy and that this
is another unfortunate thing because you
know i'm
i'm not an active player anymore so when
i do read a book i don't tend to pay so
much attention but there's a
guy a new guy around
um
i don't have it here
it starts with a k and he's written a
book finally but he's he tends to write
about things that topics that i've
always thought should be written about
oh i know what you're talking about he
went to college with me davorin
kuliasevich
yes
that's the guy hey you got it on
maryland
i mean that's when you know you're a
chess player right like oh
okay interesting subject that was good
enough for me i just read this book
you guys ought to have an act together
yeah folks i've been
really impressed with those i thought
tremendous work on long neglected
subjects i absolutely agree i think
yeah he did a really good job on both of
those books highly recommended well
jonathan you're joining the discussion
late
uh the player
who never became world champion
that you think oh my god the history of
the world would be completely different
if x
had become world champion
i didn't realize you're gonna get
surprise questions
just surprised us with that uh author
uh
it was from our social media our
audience wants to know we have a very
discerning audience by the way
so i i suppose i have to go back in time
and sort of take off all the great
um
all the obvious candidates um you only
get one sir
i'll pick one for you i'll pick one
especially for your audience it would
have been um
it's hard to cook yeah he might have
changed
the the time
space time continuum of chess how about
hikaru
there we go uh you you you took us back
uh there with that one i like that
answer wow
wow uh
turning our attention
about how the world's changed right yeah
turning our attention to the topic of
today which is the 2022 candidates
what has surprised you the most about
the tournament
your predictions that have been
unexpected
uh the play you tell us
okay i went on record just before the
event saying i had no idea whatsoever
about what would happen
uh i could see anything happening and
i'd want two rounds
to to give uh
anything resembling a prediction after
two rounds i said
i would have safe boring money if i was
going to put it down on the event and i
i thought fabi was was the
the um the favorite right after seeing
him warm up right
at the halfway point i still thought
fabi even though he was behind
because i thought
he looked like he was in
pretty close to vintage fobby form i
mean in terms of
he loved being
methodical and
unflappable and i also thought he looked
like he was in the best physical
condition which i thought was going to
be a very
key factor
um so that yeah
i will confess that was my
what became my strong opinion as soon as
you know or as late as as i formed one
um
i don't know why it took me so long to
think that the two guys who'd done it
before would actually be the favorites
it wasn't intuitively obvious at the
time no no and i was i certainly wasn't
alone that there were a lot of
distractions you got young guys and
always you think you want the romantic
angle one of the young guys
you know might do something terrific
uh you know
ding's got good numbers i think thing's
been terribly handicapped
actually by why because i mean
by a sort of lack of logistical support
maybe i mean he turned up late he's been
inactive he doesn't have a second does
he
not that he has a second but not with
him his team is back in china
okay but who who is it do you know no
they didn't reveal they just said that
he has
yeah it would be very strange if he
didn't have links to anybody or anybody
helping it but still you know it's very
long event right
so i i feel a bit sorry for him in that
respect and i think we're seeing now
him warm up yeah wouldn't surprise me if
he finishes oh the yesterday game
was very very strong jonathan we want to
thank you so much uh for taking time out
and joining us
it's first of all it's a great great
pleasure to see you remember 1976 uh
memphis tennessee those were the days
huh
[Laughter]
well you called me curly still do
i don't call you curly anymore
[Laughter]
but i must say it was
also nice to to see my you know my
breakfast chum from dubai and his
incredible
psychic ability to to know what i'm
talking about
it's a connection it's just a connection
that we built up over that breakfast
buffet
jonathan thank you so much thank you for
joining us
we uh
good to see you my friend
yes always yes take care everybody bye
bye
wonderful wow wonderful man jonathan
tisdale everybody probably